for the past decade gaming peripheral
companies have been engaged in something
of an arms race every manufacturer is
competing to create the lightest Mouse
on the market without sacrificing
performance we've come to a point where
computer mice now weigh less than a
literal living breathing actual Mouse so
at this way you basically feel like
you're holding nothing the speed at
which you can accelerate and decelerate
the mouse feels pretty much instant but
will a lighter Mouse actually make you
better at gaming or have we just gone
too far
[Applause]
all right so gaming mice have come a
long way manufacturers went from
constructing their products out of
plastic to more recently switching to
more durable materials like magnesium
alloy we've seen final Mouse Razer and
now pwnage use magnesium to create
lightweight yet sturdy products but
following the release of the magnesium
alloy tens Starlight Pro last year final
Mouse decided to do something new and so
they've recently announced their
lightest creation yet the ultralight X
we were able to achieve the greatest
generational weight reduction in our
history one integral part in making this
possible was material advancement we
implemented a Cutting Edge carbon fiber
composite on the ulx chassis that
offered us many benefits the strength
weight ratio of the new carbon fiber
composite is over three times better
than abs and a third better than
magnesium the density is better at 1.19
grams per cubic centimeter which is 30
percent less dense than magnesium while
not compromising the ultimate 10 cell
strength which is 231 megapascals final
Mouse's ultralight x-series mice are
certainly some of the lightest head
clickers we've ever seen the three mice
range from 29 to 34 grams in weight
which is absolutely insane and they were
able to do this by using a carbon fiber
composite for the shell but final Mouse
isn't actually the first manufacturer to
make a mouse out of this material back
in 2019 German company zon Koenig
released the world's first carbon fiber
gaming mouse the m1k coming in at only
23 grams it was the world's lightest
gaming mouse by a long shot and in 2021
they released a slightly heavier 24 gram
m2k with even better Hardware zankuni
says that in their eyes the best
possible gaming mouse is two things it's
as light as possible and it's designed
for fingertip grip only they actually go
as far as suggesting that the optimal
weight for a gaming mouse is zero grams
the zonkonig m2k at just 23 grams so at
this weight you basically feel like
you're holding nothing the speed at
which you can accelerate and decelerate
the mouse feels pretty much instant this
is basically as close as you can get to
aiming purely with an empty hand and
I've got to say it does feel like that
most of the time now if you're like me
you're probably looking at the m1k or
the m2k and just thinking what the
actual
am I looking at like this thing looks
ridiculous there are no side buttons
there's a cable which many people won't
like and most importantly it forces your
hand into a fingertip grip thing is that
doesn't work for a lot of Gamers so why
does unconnect believe that this is the
optimal way to play and why is it that
all manufacturers seem to think that the
only way forward is to reduce weight
well the desire for lighter mice exists
at least partially thanks to marketing
everyone wants to copy their favorite
Pros peripherals and settings so with
Faker or tens have their name on a
lightweight Mouse then people will
probably buy it but will using a lighter
Mouse actually definitively make you
better at gaming
or are we all just getting scammed to
find out we sat down with the homie
Garrick Foreman a PhD candidate at Brock
University specializing in
neuromechanics and ergonomics and here's
what he had to say so what has been
shown so far and there is very limited
work in terms of mouse weight especially
mouse weight in the context of gaming
there is some work that has shown that a
mouse weight that was under 100 grams
led to faster Target acquisition without
reducing any error in that Target
acquisition process so they could react
faster and they were more accurate when
they got to the Target so as Garrett
just said there is some research to
suggest that there's a correlation
between Target acquisition speed and
mouse weight with lighter mice typically
performing better that being said there
was an interesting study conducted last
year by students at the University of
California Berkeley they tried to
determine what mouse weight offers the
best overall performance by using a fits
test which basically looked at how long
long it takes you to reach an object in
relation to its width and distance from
you to perform gaming tasks in fortnite
and the results were pretty interesting
but to present their findings I brought
along my good old trusty sidekick Colton
since I know that the only thing that he
loves more than science
fortnite ain't that right pal and now
the guy who actually knows what he's
talking about
you smell that that's the smell of a
fresh research article now I may not be
a certified Fortnight gamer but I am a
Scientist at heart and there's nothing I
love more than digging into gaming
related scholarly papers so let's break
down their study 12 participants aged 18
to 29 with an average of 13.7 hours of
gaming under their belts each week those
are rookie numbers we got to pump those
numbers up tested six different mice
ranging from 40 to 140 grams in weight
one of the six mice were selected
randomly and participants had to perform
a Fitz test and a gaming task on
fortnite for 10 minutes before
completing a survey about how they felt
about the mouse's performance they
repeated this for all six mice before
completing a final survey where they
ranked all of them based on how
comfortable they were and which Mouse
they preferred so what did they actually
find out well even though the 40 gram
mouse was rated as being the most
comfortable it actually had the worst
scores in terms of precision the 40 gram
Mouse averaged an 11.32 error rate and
target re-entries of 0.20 compared to
the overall average of 9.97 and 0.15
respectively this isn't some
earth-shattering difference but the
trend of increasing in accuracy across
lighter mice has been noted in other
studies unsurprisingly the chunky 140
gram most recorded the lowest overall
preference score and the 60 gram most
actually proved to be The Sweet Spot
receiving the highest marks from the
participants and when you really think
about it the modern Mouse Market really
backs this up some of the most popular
mice on the market right now like the
super light and the DeathAdder V3 Pro
both weigh in at roughly 60 grams but
this study of course has its
shortcomings which the authors
themselves include the first of which is
the participant's muscle memory for
example every time Niall tests out a new
mouse for us it often takes him weeks to
start to feel comfortable with a new
weight or shape and lighter mice may
even exacerbate the learning curve as
the study notes they saw increased
muscle activity when using the lightest
Mouse which could quote indicate that
there is a point where a mouse gets too
light for some users possibly by
reducing the amount of proprioceptive
input to the user which in plain English
just means that below a certain weight
it may actually become more difficult
for your nervous system to keep track of
how your wrist hand and arm are actually
moving making you less accurate so the
fact that these participants were given
less than 15 minutes with each Mouse
isn't exactly ideal and I know our
friend Garrick agrees I think a lot of
the research is just imperfect
um and I have other grievances with the
research as well is that if for example
I use a my chunky Logitech g502 that
weighs 127 grams or something like that
and then I drop immediately to a 60 gram
Mouse I'm going to perform worse a lot
of the research out there looks at the
gram
change like the difference in mouse
weight the grammage change if you will
without allowing people to acclimate and
get used to a new mouse before assessing
either performance or muscle activity
now if you are considering the jump to a
lighter Mouse there are some things you
can do to help with that transition like
adjusting your sensitivity to account
for the different levels of friction one
might feel from a lighter or heavier
Mouse I think that if you're used to
something specific it does kind of tie
into a lot of like you know the
adjustments if if you can make your new
Mouse as close to your old mouse you
kind of I think Stave off the learning
curve a little bit and then once you've
gotten used to the new weight you can
then make the changes you want if you
feel like you can get an edge either
with a higher or lower sensitivity in
combination with the wage change so what
did we learn today don't just listen to
marketing kids lighter is not
necessarily better it's much more
important to balance your overall muscle
Comfort over long-term use with your
ability to move the mouse precisely it's
pretty obvious that a quote-unquote
light Mouse will help in this area but
exactly how light is going to come down
to experimenting yourself and that was
the guy who actually knows what he's
talking about but regardless of what
Gamers may prefer lightweight mice are
definitely becoming more common there
was a time when mice didn't go below 80
grams but nowadays companies get roasted
for releasing new mice without shaving
off excess weight and although we'll
likely need more research to prove
scientifically that lighter mice do in
fact make you better at gaming the
research that we do have does seem to
suggest that the science so far does say
that a lower mouse weight provides
better
performance there definitely needs to be
more research done to look at the
intricacies of that and really get get
into the nitty-gritty of the details of
what actually is better performance
where does that stop as you're saying
have we gone too far I don't know so
while we still don't know the exact
optimal weight for a gaming mouse there
are definitely tons of lightweight
options to choose from my colleagues and
I haven't even used a mouse lighter than
45 grams and my favorite go-to Mouse
comes in at 82 so some of these new sub
30 gram products sound absolutely insane
but to come back to the original
question have we gone too far
well apparently we still have a ways to
go when it comes to the ultimate
lightweight Mouse what if there was some
a little like glove that you put on
logically that would be the most
accurate movement because you're not
manipulating any additional weight
theoretically the closer we get to zero
grams the closer we get to more fluid
and controlled arm movements because you
don't have to manipulate anything with
your hands and who knows maybe one day
we'll be gaming without a mouse in our
hands at all
so they brought it from 82 grams down to
72 grams the 72 grams I can't use it I
can't use it I've tried for like a year
and a half it's too light so I've
reverted back to the original zowie
weight the 82 and I have better aim with
it I have better performance it's more
comfortable 82 anything lower than that
too light for me